hi my name is Peggy Johnson luma
executive vice president of global
market development for Qualcomm we had a
terrific panel today on rethinking
education I brought together two people
from business one from the government
side and one student and we're ugly
agree on some of the basic principles
learning who were they all agreed that
technology play a very important role
and be an asset to the delivery of
education with other wireless networks
all of us agreed that technology that is
current state can already begin to be
effective in our classrooms today the
other thing we agreed on is that it
could be a great equalizer for students
I was very surprised to learn about this
significant number of private schools in
Latin America and response to some of
the educational quality issues they were
male in public schools so I think
technology again and play a great little
there and then lastly we all agreed on
the fact that it was a solution to this
problem is really going to be a
collaboration between government the
private sector teachers parents and the
students themselves we all need to come
together to solve this problem it's not
going to be any one of us thank you